it's a really interesting notion that
the ambiguity of language is
a feature yeah and we evolved
for millions of years to uh
to take advantage of that ambiguity
exactly and yet
no one teaches us the subtle differences
between words that are near cognates
and yet evoke so much more than you know
one from the other
and yet you know when you're choosing
words from
a list of 20 synonyms you know exactly
the connotation of every single one of
them
and that's something that you know is
there so so
yes there's ambiguity but there's all
kinds of connotations and in the way
that we select our words
we have so much baggage that we're
sending along the way that we're
emoting the way that we're moving our
hands every single time we speak
the you know the pauses the eye contact
etc
so much higher baud rate than just the
vocal you know
string of characters well let me just
take a small
tangent on that oh tangent we haven't
done that yet and haven't done
it uh we'll return to the origin of life
so i mean you're greek but i'm i'm going
on this
personal journey um i'm going to paris
for the explicit purpose of uh
talking to one of the most famous uh a
couple who's the famous translators of
russian
literature dostoyevsky tolstoy yeah and
they go
that's their art is the translation and
um everything i've learned about the
translation art
it makes me feel um
it's so profound in a way that's
so much more profound than the natural
language processing papers i read in the
machine learning community
that there's such depth to language
that i don't know what to do with i
don't know if you've experienced that in
your own life
with knowing multiple languages
i don't know what to i don't know how to
make sense of it but there's so much
loss in translation between russian and
english
and getting a sense of that like for
example
there's like just taking a single
sentence from dostoyevsky
and like there's a lot of them you could
you could talk for
hours about how to translate that
sentence properly
uh that captures the meaning the the
the period the culture the humor the wit
the suffering that was in the context of
the time
all of that it could be a single
sentence uh you could
you could talk forever about what it
takes to translate that correctly i
don't know what to do with that
so uh being greek it's very hard for me
to think of a
sentence or even a word without going
into the full etymology of that word
breaking up every single atom of
that that sentence and every single atom
of these words
and rebuilding it back up i have three
kids
and the way that i teach them greek is
the same way that you know the
documentary i was mentioning earlier
about sort of understanding the deep
roots of all of these
you know words um
and it's very
it's very interesting that every single
time i hear a new word that i've never
heard before
i go and figure out the etymology of
that word because i will never
appreciate that word
without understanding how it was
initially formed
interesting but how does that help
because that's that's not the full
picture
no no of course of course but what i'm
trying to say is that knowing the
components
teaches you about the context of the
formation of that word and sort of the
original usage of that word
and then of course the word takes new
meaning as you create it
you know from its parts and
that meaning then gets augmented and two
synonyms
that that sort of have different roots
will actually have implications that
carry a lot of that baggage
of the historical provenance of these
words so before working on genome
evolution
my passion was evolution of language
and sort of tracing cognates across
different languages
through their etymologies and that's
fascinating that there's parallels
between i mean of course
the idea that huge amount there's
evolutionary dynamics to our language
yeah every single word that you
order parallels parallels what does
parallels mean
para means side by side alleles from
alleles which means
identical twins parallels i mean
name any word and there's so much
baggage so much
beauty in how that word came to be and
how this word took a new meaning
than the sum of its parts
yeah and that and those and they're just
they're just words they don't have any
physical
exactly and now you take those words and
you weave them
into a sentence the emotional
invocations of that weaving are
fathomless and they're all all of those
emotions
all live in our in the brains of humans
in the eye of the beholder is the eye
no seriously you have to embrace this
concept of the eye of the beholder
it's it's the the conceptualization that
nothing takes meaning with one person
creating it everything takes meaning
in the receiving end and the emergent
properties
of these communication networks where
every single you know if you look at the
network of our cells and how they're
communicating with each other
every cell has its own code this code is
modulated by the epigenome this creates
a bunch of different cell types each
cell type now has its own identity
yet they all have the common root of the
stem cells that sort of led to them
each of these identities is now
communicating with each other
they take meaning in their interaction
there's an emergent property that comes
from a bunch of cells being together
that is not in any one of the parts if
you look at neurons communicating again
these n-grams
don't exist in any one neuron they exist
in the connection in the combination of
neurons
and the meaning of the words that i'm
telling you
is empty until it reaches you and it
affects you in a very different way
than it affects whoever's listening to
this conversation now
because of the emotional baggage that
i've grown up with that you've grown up
with and that they've grown up with
yeah and that's i think the magic of
translation
if you start thinking of translation as
just simply capturing that emotional
set of reactions that you have that you
evoke
you need a different set of words to
evoke that same set of reactions to a
french person
than to a russian person because of the
baggage of the culture that we grew up
in
yeah i mean there's so so basically you
shouldn't find the best
word sometimes it's a completely
different sentence structure that you
will need
matched to the cultural context
of the target audience that you have
yeah the it's it's i mean
you're just i usually don't think about
this but right now
there's this feeling as a reminder that
it's just you and i talking
but there's several hundred thousand
people will listen to this
there's some guy in russia right now
running
uh like in moscow listening to us
and there's somebody in india i
guarantee you there's somebody in china
in south america there's somebody
in texas and and they all have different
emotional baggage they probably got
angry earlier on about the whole
discussion about coronavirus and
uh about some aspect of it uh yeah it's
and there's that network effect yeah
yeah
that's uh it's a beautiful thing and and
this lateral transfer of information
that's what makes the collective
quote-unquote genome
of humanity so unique from any other
species
you